vi ricordate il blog mas dell'anno
scorso sappiate questo è bello ciò o
dimenticate tutto quest anno fa in
qualcosa di ancora più epico abbiamo
affittato una casa per tutto con te mese
di dicembre io c'ho mar
enrico la linea stiamo già aspettando
altri ospiti tutto in mega sicurezza di
ogni giorno dalle 14 un video su youtube
cremo contenuti su instagram sul tik tok
e dalle 19 siccome ciò che resta a tutti
quanti insieme inizieremo a fare delle
stream live su cui segnatevi queste date
io adesso sono quelli comodo su questo
letto di questa bellissima stanza che
non è mia
questa bellissima casa che non era mia
con questo dolcissimo cane e non è mio è
un ha concluso spero che mi possa
divertire diciamo un salto indietro nel
passato e vediamo come si ricorderà wers
lista è la situazione macchina al
momento la robaccia teatro piatti poldo
non so nemmeno se quello che sto facendo
sia legale o no
siamo quasi arrivati all'abitazione fa
da quella parte tutto a posto che solo
una cosa che ti terrorizza
ieri il ragazzo è stato quei minuti a
provare ad aprire la porta non entreremo
male non ho capito come si apre non ci
credono di giuro lui mi dice che vanno
allineati due cose
le ho provate vediamo tu magari il
nostro il meccanismo che vuol dire come
sono uno scassinatore prima voglio
vedere bloccato ti gira la serratura
odio si fidano e possibile ce la farai
a lui si è stato parecchio
tale deve pronti a vedere il delirio
bene complimenti e sepolto vivo per fare
più spazio poi ho messo tutti i sedili
dritti consigli tu non hai che tieni la
camera e ci guardi però io devo fare il
blog ragazzi pure quello lì è anche il
resto un culo che ha lasciato totalmente
nella merda quello di qua dobbiamo
ottimizzando farsi mela mangiata
mascherina tarantolati della porta
[Risate]
chiedo scusa
confermiamo così il fosso tn questo caso
di ladri
meno male la signora caterina sei
riuscito ha deciso una scalata un'altra
chiave a piedi di porco certa mascherin
si mise rotta ma cosa devi sussurrare
alla volta a queste sono a crescere non
mi sembra comunque piacevole come come
scusa ma che stai scherzando
bene possiamo mandare andiamo io sono
sconvolto frico posso sapere cosa non
fai alle donne
no io vado subito a scegliere la mia
stanza arriva la vita
perché sulla spalla sta cagando sotto
certo è terrorizzato lo riguardano una
balconata
abbiamo cercato di fare vedere i gatti a
questo nuovo ambiente mare come serena
ma nel peso in passato aspetta perché
devo far vedere dove sono finiti i
cuginetti non ci credo 1 ma perché dei
ragazzi è diventata una zona 6 1 ci
mancano due libri amore di dio quanto
sei bello mezz'ore come se non fosse
abbastanza difficile convivere in tutti
questi esseri umani siamo anche un
serraglio
ma io ho un problema il mio ritiene di
essere un essere umano quindi non sono
in grado di farlo convivere con gli
altri gatti e conculde perché io così
non può fare ciò anche le altre bestie
bibe di muoversi manca soltanto il gatto
nero mamma aiutateci aiutateci
buongiorno benvenuto avete già fatto
tutte la casa famoso panino io voglio
vedere il tour della casa fatto da
gabriele accolti dal bagno in comune
anche il cazzo vuole questo piano
da che sciava sulla pista scusa di sheen
diakitè che aggiunge io numeri sono
andate a me piace sarà che cos'è ottico
300 le termopili che affrontano i
persiani negli spazi stretti dai
proseguiamo con fronte una mamma dove
sta che eccesso di no ma rispetto ad
autobus
questo è un bellissimo e mio sono pagate
tutti i sanitari in un sospesi
non c'è trucco non c'è inganno
l'esposizione vediamo subito nord ci
avete il cesso credo ti congelato il
culo e molte persone famiglia possiamo
conoscere la tua stanza ma greco la sua
fan
sei diventata mamma il resto posso
fermarmi qui import e rilassate un
bambino così delizioso padre di questo
spazio più grande della camera mia di
san marco è morto e non avendo c'è il
nord farà fini ma perchè prima o poi ci
saranno ha detto che l'artista non è
male il pisa che quando entra 11 ospiti
indesiderati
sono stato la camera più piccola non
l'ho presa io mi hanno lasciato insomma
capitolo per scambiarsi noi c'era fine
mi è rimasto questo piccolo molto tempo
della pole per non è una scheda polvere
che bene questo qui dai sono 12 non ti
azzardare mai più anzi se potessi
togliere le scarpe di note con te sei fu
chiamato proprio o ragazzi posso dire
una cosa
salt esposizione sud potete seguirmi un
secondo il quale chi altro si è preso un
esposizione a sud nella mia ragazzi ma
chi è questa direi meglio io di
carbonari della nave siamo sopra di
tutto lo devi sapere impennare quanti se
ci salveremo di ma per marino che le
pensi del televisore alle spalle
leggendo libro imbrò bello mascia bello
come riposa occhi 22 mar
ma che si mangia qua attraversati da
grappa pulito ed io ho fame non a
comprare qualcosa ma ci si sbagliava
diciamo fame
mamma mia in castello voglia di far da
mangiare
questo gesto sapete che vuol dire che
non ci sono i miei [ __ ] colpo anche
mar adesso quando la bambina
cioè di un [ __ ] aprire perché quasi
tutti maschili
in tutto questo una delle cose che ci
terrorizza di più che a partire dalle 19
inseriamo le line su twitter e faremo
ore e ore di live ogni giorno guardate
intanto la vigna ormai è un regista
pazzesca ragazzi io sono la dj sulle
mani
abbiamo tutta una serie di roba di
attrezzatura guarda che è un disastro è
un design far parlare tutto è avere
tutto andiamo online o che cosa
decine di cavi decine di attrezzature
telecamere ovunque è veramente ambizioso
forse troppo ci vediamo in live alle 19
a parte gli scherzi ragazzi venite a 19
sul nostro twitch e vi lasciamo il link
qua sotto e venite a sostenerci
soprattutto perché siamo terrorizzati di
fare una non lo dico cagata infinita ma
che cos'è all'alba ma state veramente
perdendo il seno fino a questo punto
siamo un ora che stiamo avviando con
ricavi ed attaccando casi attaccando
console
tu cosa stavi facendo siamo riuniti per
che stiamo cercando di gufare in realtà
non vogliamo che questa live possa
andare life cioè immaginatevi di nuovo
perché ci sarà prorompenza da guarda
quel che ho capito quindi chi ve se
schioppa schioppa uno come si dice in
gergo incrociamo le dita che fuoco i
fili oppure posso fare a come mio solito
non allenarmi appena citofonato gabriele
col cibo meno male sto morendo di fame
che avrete
hanno regalato comunicare carini ma non
è un telefono in portafoglio domani
[Applauso]
signore un attimo un regime a questa
casa c'è un mezzo vi sono ma non siamo
cioè abbastanza light il tutto ok line
nel senso perché non è tanto muse un
porco quanta mangiamo e aspetta che da
qualche tempo ma che preso che è sta
roba molto invitante capriati certo
posso dire un tentacolo gli stessi di
quanto riguarda l'anno in seriosissima
si respira una buona atmosfera in casa
però su una cosa io sono certo tempo due
o tre giorni e vorremmo già ucciderci a
vicenda almeno io sono sicuro commettere
un crimine poi guglielmo mi ha detto che
vuole far entrare nella casa
un ospite segreto
chi è questo ospite segreto per sé
perché ho bisogno di trasformare questa
casa nella casa dei mcallister mai
cercato l'ho voluta e lavorare stasera
in diretta alle 19 partiamo con
prorompenza tutto hicks il primo
appuntamento che siamo tutti aspettando
qui non ci stiamo capendo niente perché
pieno dei cani
prima ci alleniamo poi ci spostiamo in
cucina fino a tarda notte a mezzanotte
ancora con podcast a parlare ma
vendemmiare latitudine nata sotto la
verità è che quasi un secondo la verità
è che siamo in alto mare vi prego de
mita 19 su twitter che stavate tutti
diventando è il momento che pensavate mi
voglio rovinare dove dei pezzi prendi
qualcosa che mi ha guardato comprando
questo non lo ha comprato io è un rotolo
per i dolci tutto per andare in diretta
raga ci vediamo stasera alle 19 su
twitter altro se credete a cosa serva
questo per andare in diventato il tris
questo collega le camere si che abbiamo
tre camere si è stesa l'anno le camere
una la voglio puntata qui una punta da
qui e l'altra voglio un maxi master
ok la guarda a parte gli scherzi stasera
alle 19 c una mano perché ragazzi
veramente quando si sa come fare però
sarà un successo tutto in live tutto in
diretta tutto stasera a cena da me
talmente stasera alle 19 sotto i 5 mila
a guardarci vi prego e domani alle 4
fila sul gobbo poi poi mangiamo in
diretta bambina merda 9000 mezza nata è
tutto qui non comprate dopo lo stress il
momento nella musica no la faccio io no
c'è la musica si commette ragazzi stiamo
facendo una cosa che i ragazzi sono una
cosa pazzesca se viene bene che in una
bomba ma bomba se viene male viene un
disastro comunque ci vediamo stasera 19
su twitter e mi raccomando domani alle
14 nella puntata del blog mas e vinco
hai fatto un intervento
[Risate]
chi e disco chiedi scusa per il video
che appena andati in onda